hi guys
all right so let's begin
e4
yeah i think he's normally a big french
player so this isn't too much of a
surprise
bishop g5
[Music]
i think we only played one game in the
french a number of years ago
okay 97 is the most common move
knight b to d7 that is let's see he
looks like he's um
thinking about which line to play okay
this line is
also decent knife three
now let's castle long and try to attack
castle long this should be seven
let's try h4 bishop d3
and some knights of g5 is normally what
i want
i like c5
i think something like this exists h5 h6
you should probably stop this with h6 i
think i don't know
he shouldn't allow my pawn to get there
like cd4 h6
g6 queen d4 is all sorts of trouble for
him
so i suspect h6 is the correct move
let's see um
queen c7 so i think i'll take the
opportunity to play this
queen queen
king d1 comes to mind looks like a
decent move
all right let's just do that safe enough
i have some ideas of queen c3 and then
d5 or dc5 but i wanted to get it out of
the way of potential checks on f4
so i think knight f6 makes sense but
then knight takes c5 he doesn't want to
i don't want to get that so let's see
we could try to take on g4 queen d4 e5
um makes some sense
i'm not too worried about that position
even end games look
kind of nicer like queen c4 take take
um think i should
plan i take c5 here
e6 so he's just going for a straight
pawn sacrifice that's probably a good
plan for him to put the knight on d3
knight on e5 looks decent
i should d3 i'm up upon but i'm not
attacking him anymore
so i understand why he went for this
bishop d3
if he takes i take over tonight so i'm
not losing a pawn i just want to
continue
maybe it was like rookie one
[Music]
c3 knight g5 something
if i get knight too far there's some
saxon f7 i could
start to consider yeah next move just
rookie one
um he's a bit short of counter play
i don't know what he's gonna do
95 okay so here's some knight before
stuff coming
c3 f6 should i be worried about rookie
one
night uh knight before bishop before
i don't think there's anything to be
concerned about there but then bishop
before actually c3s takes
c3f6 is not really what i wanted
uh
yeah it's not
i should just make a decision look at
one i don't like
all right let's just go for this let's
find f6 i'll move my knight back to e3
or something
not really what i was going through too
at least f6 is a very serious weakness
position
so it's not um
maybe not exactly what he wants
okay that's uh that's a bit of relief
now that's the rookie one
he wants to play b5 but b5 is not a
threatening move for me
um
the bishop on c2
just kind of regret that i spent so much
time on that decision to play c3
might be six okay let's put the bishop
on b
[Music]
three
so he'll you might play knight c4
i see 422 bishop d5 actually he does
have some
a decent blockade on on the light
squares
then a5 let's see does this worry me i
mean i have knight f7
it's kind of brave to allow that
a497 take 98
let's try queen e2 if a41 play knight f7
ab3 knight d8 b8 will play king a1
he'll take on d8 probably with the
bishop
play queen e6 it looks really terrifying
for him
okay it's good enough nothing to go for
maybe not the right decision but
i get so many pawns that even if i'm not
attacking it
can't be so bad
yeah i don't think he can take on f7
bishop v6 h do this he should take on a2
force king a1 take with the bishop i
think
i don't rooktext king of eight i don't
know this
queen takes but queen e6 what what's
going on look up 795 that's just way
more
i should do five knight of seven yeah i
think okay
looks good enough
i don't see any tricks my king on a1 is
very safe
okay so next game